The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So let's get
going on system integration
and interface management.
So we're essentially moving
up the right side of the V.
And the idea is all the
details have been designed.
The concept has been selected.
We know what we're doing, but
now we have to re-integrate
the system and make
sure it works--
it performs the functions
that are intended
and satisfies the requirements.
And so what I'm going to
cover today is three things.
First of all, why do we care?
Why is interface
management important?
Why is it important?
There's two main reasons.
One is because a lot
of failures originate--
so a lot of failures
originate at interfaces.
And the other reason
is because in order
to design and manufacture
a lot of systems,
we need to work with
partners and suppliers.
And I'll talk about interface
management, sort of the details
of it, the types of interfaces.
I'll Introduce the DSM, the
Design Structure Matrix,
as an important method.
And then we'll talk about ICDs,
Interface Control Documents.
They're a very big
deal in practice.
And then finally, I'll talk
about system integration--
in particular, the sequence
which you integrate systems,
and then the role of standards.
All right, so here, the point
that I want to make here
is when you talk
about interfaces,
the first thing you need
to be clear is, is it
an internal interface
or an external interface
of the system?
And so I think you remember
this chart here that has--
is this you guys--
that has a system
boundary that's defined.
So the system
boundary, in this case,
we have this
digital camera here.
And the internal interfaces
are essentially the interfaces
that are within this boundary.
So those are internal
interfaces within the camera,
within the peripherals, that
are included in the system
boundary.
And then we have
external interfaces,
which would be the interfaces
between the system boundary
and anything that's
on the outside
that you don't design
or control directly.
So that's an
important distinction.
The next point I want
to make is that you
have to really carefully think
about interfaces as seeds
of potential system failures.
And so I have three
examples here for you.
So the first one is--
this is actually--
Katya, sorry, this is
from Russia, from 2007.
This is traffic.
This is one of the big--
not [RUSSIAN],, but
prospekt, the six lanes
or eight lanes on
one side, and there's
a crossroad coming in here.
This is a traffic intersection.
And you can see
traffic is completely
blocked on this side.
So traffic engineers think
a lot about interfaces,
which are mainly your
intersections, the roundabouts.
Interfaces are really where a
traffic system makes or breaks
the traffic system.
So that's a bottleneck.
An interface is a
bottleneck, basically.
The second example here
in the middle, this
is actually an example from
MIT from an undergraduate class
in design where the students
were designing an airfoil.
So this has been produced
with a foam cutter.
And you have a spar
that goes through here.
And this was intended for
the MIT Formula SAE race car
to create downward
pressure on the rear axle.
They tested it in
the wind tunnel,
and it worked well at 20 miles
per hour, 40 miles per hour.
And then at 60 miles per
hour, there was a failure,
and the airfoil just
basically disintegrated
and was carried off
into the wind tunnel
and completely shredded
by the propeller.
Why did that happen?
Well, they thought
about the shear loads.
So when you have
an airfoil, there's
a force that's acting
orthogonally to the airfoil.
So they thought about that.
The problem is there's also a
torque, like a pitching moment,
a torque that's generated.
And the higher the air speed
is, the higher the torque.
They didn't think-- there
was no real good way
to react against the torque
that was being generated.
So at that high speed, the
airfoil, all of a sudden,
tilted and created a lot of drag
and basically was destroyed.
So the airfoil itself was OK,
but the interface was not.
The third example here is a
software example or a software
interface, very famous.
This was the launch
failure of the Ariane 501.
The very first launch
of the Ariane 5
basically led to an
auto-destruct of the rocket
upon ascent.
There was an accident
investigation.
And I'm just quoting you here
from the key passage, which
said that "the active initial
reference system transmitted
essentially diagnostic
information to the launcher's
main computer."
And so the main computer was
interpreting this information
as though the rocket has
gone off course and trying
to correct for it when,
in fact, it hadn't.
It was actually physically going
exactly the right trajectory,
but it was misinterpreted.
And this is also a very famous
failure due to software reuse.
So three examples of
interfaces-- bottlenecks
in traffic, structural
failures, and erroneous function
calls in software.
And so be careful
about interfaces.
The second reason we care is
working with manufacturers
and suppliers.
So the picture
here is essentially
the Dreamliner, the Boeing 787.
And you can see here the
different colors essentially
represent the
different countries
or the different suppliers that
are providing different parts
of the airplane.
Now, does anybody-- let me
ask this question to MIT,
see if we can hear them now.
No?
Well, maybe we can use the chat.
What's different
between the Dreamliner--
and you could have seen
a similar picture, say,
for the 737 or prior
generation aircraft.
So what's the real difference
here with the interfaces,
with the 787?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yeah, that's true.
Composites is one thing, but
that's a structural thing.
I have something else in mind.
There's some other fundamental
change that was made in the 787
beyond composites.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Nope.
OLIVIER DE WECK: This has to
do with the way the airplane is
assembled, with assembly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yes, yes, exactly.
So the supply chain
is very different.
And I guess I lost my--
hm, did I reverse this?
So the point I want to
make is that in the 787,
the modules are
essentially pre-outfitted.
Like, all the systems,
like the electrical system,
the hydraulics, everything
is already installed
by the time the module
arrives at the assembly
plant in Everett and
close to Seattle.
Before, you got the
structural sections, but then
all the electricals, all
the inside was done on site.
So the modules are pre-outfitted
with all the subsystems.
And the final assembly itself
is very short, only a few days.
So a big, big step, and
that's exactly right.
That's the supply chain impact.
OK, so then the
final point here is
this is essentially
a launch vehicle
design, a launch
vehicle that's being
designed at NASA, the SLS.
And if you think about
a launch vehicle,
you have the first stage, second
stage, third stage, payload,
the fairing.
Actually, a lot
of these fairings
are made here in Switzerland.
And defining these
interfaces very clearly
is critical to
reduce complexity.
Understanding the
different types, which
we're going to get into next--
identifying the interfaces
is a way to reduce risk.
And I just talked
about these problems
originating at interfaces.
And so hopefully,
it's pretty clear now
that this is a critical issue.
So what I'd like to
do now-- and we'll
try to troubleshoot the audio
issues in the meantime--
is for you to turn to
your partner exercise
and share with
each other, what is
an instance in your
past experience,
maybe during an internship or
in a project that you worked on,
where interface definition
and management was critical?
AUDIENCE: Some of us went this
summer to Russia, to Moscow,
to follow a summer camp on
system engineering and space
engineering.
And we had a project
there where we
had to design a
mission to deep space.
And everyone was
assigned to a group.
The groups were around
five to seven people,
and there were five
to seven groups.
And each group had a
subsystem to design,
but no group was assigned
to system engineering.
So actually, there was
no one to make sure
that all the interfaces were OK.
So we had to go to
each other group
and ask for the interfaces.
And then when we had to
go back, it was a mess.
And at the end, every
group had something good.
But when we tried to put
all the systems together,
it was a big mess and
nothing was working.
OLIVIER DE WECK: That's a
pitch for systems engineering.
So that's a good point.
So even if you negotiate
bilateral interfaces
amongst subsystems,
there's no guarantee
that it will work
at the system level.
OK, can we get from MIT?
Can somebody give us
what you discussed?
AUDIENCE: Is this
the mic working?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah,
now we can hear you.
AUDIENCE: Great.
So my grad school
project here at MIT
is a secondary payload
on a big NASA mission.
And as a secondary payload,
the interface control
is a really big deal.
So we're getting
all of our power
and all of our communication
from the spacecraft,
and we're also getting a
heater circuit from them.
So any change is a big deal.
We had to change
our heater circuit
and we had to go through
a lot of paperwork
just to splice a wire.
So no issue with it, but it's
not as easy as it sounds,
and there's a lot of control
over it, I would say.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, maybe
another example from MIT.
Somebody else?
AUDIENCE: Does this work?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the--
OLIVIER DE WECK: We've got
it fixed out now, by the way.
I think this is all
working now, so good.
AUDIENCE: The last
project I was a part
of was building an aircraft
for a Red Bull Flugtag.
So it was like a giant glider
that we'd push off a platform.
But we were kind of
building it in a hurry.
The time constraints
were pretty quick,
and we didn't really
have all the requirements
until a month or two
before the competition.
So we winged a lot of the
design and construction.
And so we thought about
how to build the wing
and how to build the empennage
and how to build the cockpit,
but we didn't think about
how to put them all together.
And so it turned out just being
wrapped with a lot of carbon
fiber and epoxied.
And in some cases, we used wood.
And it was a very heavy and
poor-looking assembly once all
that was together.
Even though each part
individually looked great,
they didn't really come
together perfectly.
So we'll change that next year,
but could have thought more.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
Great example.
All right, so
hopefully, this is sort
of motivation that, in
a sense, a system is
the functions you want, the
components, and the interfaces.
You've got to have all three.
If you only have
great components
but you don't understand
the interfaces,
you stick them together, I'm not
sure what you're going to get.
Yes, do you want to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Is it
also important the interfaces
with testing facilities?
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yeah, absolutely.
So testability requirements,
how you're going to test it,
is critical.
Also, ground support
equipment-- you know,
like maintenance equipment.
So not just the
interfaces, the system
when you're operating
it, but during testing,
during maintenance.
And those are often forgotten
as well, so great point.
So let's keep moving here.
I want to talk about
the types of interfaces,
and then we'll get to DSM.
So here's a set of examples of
interfaces that we encounter.
Let's see if we can get
the slides back up here.
So essentially,
here's some examples.
In the upper left, we
have a valve, and then
a tank on the right side.
And we essentially
have mass flow
from the valve to the
tank, and m dot, dm dt.
We have a rocket.
If you think about the rocket
interface with the payload,
it's transferring
momentum, right?
The rocket provides
thrust, force F,
for some amount
of time, delta-t,
and that's the
momentum imparted.
We have a heat
exchanger that is maybe
giving heat off to the
air, the surrounding air.
So we have a heat flux, q dot.
We have solar cells,
PV cells, that
are producing electrical
power, voltage times current.
And this power flux is being
sent to a battery where
the energy is stored.
So these are all pretty
obvious examples.
And then on the
right side, things
get maybe a little
bit less obvious.
You go to a URL and you download
an HTML file into your browser.
That's an information.
You're getting data.
You have a motion sensor
attached, say, to your house,
and it triggers an alarm.
That's a command,
different from data.
NPR is National Public Radio.
This is kind of the high-quality
radio news reporting.
And you listen to this.
So there's a
cognitive interface.
And then if any of you
have had any psychotherapy,
this is also an interface
between the patient
and the psychotherapist.
This is an effective interface.
So these are very different.
And you can say,
well, there's hundreds
of types of interfaces.
Well, no.
The argument here
is all interfaces
can be reduced or described
by these four canonical types.
The first one is
physical connection.
So A connects to
B. B connects to A.
A physical connection
typically implies
that there's a
force or torque that
can be transmitted
across the interface,
and it's always symmetrical.
And then we have energy,
mass, and information flows.
And I'll give you
some examples of each
of these types of interfaces.
And these energy, mass
and information flows
typically are asymmetric.
It flows from one to the other.
Physical connection
is always symmetric.
So let's go through these,
and I'll give you examples.
And then we'll see
what can we do with it.
So here's physical
connection examples--
rollers, brake pads.
A finger touching a touch
screen is a physical interface.
The interface can be reversible.
In other words, the
connection is temporary--
and examples of that would
be electrical connectors,
USB ports, latch
mechanisms, nuts and bolts--
or permanently connected,
such as in-- so one of you
mentioned riveting,
spot welding, fusing.
And a fun question
that comes up,
well, I'm a software engineer.
What is physical connection
mean for software?
Well, it's a kind
of tricky question.
I think the closest analog
we have is compiling.
If you have pieces
of source code
and you compile your
program, then you've
essentially fused this together
into something new, right?
So I'll show you the example.
So how do we describe it?
Well, here's an OPM model of--
I'll give you a couple
examples from xerography.
So we have a main
motor here, number one,
and then two different clutches,
number two and number three.
And the process linking
them is engaging, right?
The main motor engages
through the clutch.
We can hide the
process, and then
we just have this bi-directional
interface between one and two
and one and three.
And then if we show this
as a mini-DSM here, one
connected to two, one
connected to three,
but two and three do not connect
directly with each other.
They don't have a direct
physical interface.
And you can see that because
those cells are empty.
So physical connection
implies symmetry
in the design structure
matrix that we can build up.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Oh, DSM--
so DSM means Design
Structure Matrix.
And I will introduce
that in a minute.
We've briefly mentioned
it before in the class,
but I'll get into
it in some detail.
Here's some more
picture examples
of physical connections--
so a welding joint,
irreversible, reversible, nuts
and bolts, RJ45, an
electrical connector.
And then here's your--
hey, I'm an old guy.
I learned Fortran.
Well, Basic was my first
language, and then Fortran.
I did a lot of Fortran.
You guys probably don't
even know what that is.
But Fortran--
right, [INAUDIBLE]??
Fortran's kind of a big
deal still in some--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
So basically the way this works
is you have your source code,
which are .f files.
These are basically
Ascii files, right?
And then first, you transform
them into binary files,
object files.
And then these get merged
together into an executable.
So that's the
process of compiling.
Any questions about
physical connections,
this type of interface,
physical connection?
Is it clear?
OK, any questions at MIT?
Can you still hear me?
AUDIENCE: Yes, we're good.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
So let's move on
to energy flows.
Energy flows are present when
there's a net exchange of work
between two components.
So power is flowing across
the interface dw dt, right--
joules per second, watts.
And the energy, this energy
flow, this power flow,
can take different forms--
electrical power, which is
very common in many products.
And so the electrical
power usually
comes either as DC, Direct
Current, or AC, Alternating
Current.
And if you know a little
bit about the history
of electrical systems and
networks, there was a huge war.
It's called the AC/DC wars.
It's not the band.
This is not the rock music.
This is the war
between Edison, who
is a big proponent
of direct current,
and Tesla and Westinghouse,
who were really pushing
AC for big power distribution.
So we won in the end?
AC won.
It looked initially
like Edison was really--
and there's still,
in New York City,
there, for a long
time, and other places,
you still had DC power systems.
The problem with
DC power is there's
huge losses with distance.
And with AC, you can go
to very high voltages
and transmit power with
relatively little loss
over large distance.
That's the main reason that
AC won out, essentially.
The thing that's important
here-- and power, of course,
is current times voltage.
The thing that's important is
that these voltage levels--
and in the case of AC
power also, the frequency
is very important,
50 or 60 hertz.
This is very standardized, OK?
So if you're going to design a
satellite system, or a rover,
or an automotive system, or a
medical device or a consumer
product, the voltage
levels are pretty--
there's a few choices,
but you can't just
choose some arbitrary number,
because your whole industry,
your batteries, your
connectors, everything is now
pretty standardized.
So for the Octanus 1,
Rafael, what did you guys
choose for your power system?
What's your--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 3.3 volts.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
3.3-volt bus across, OK.
And then if you
need more energy,
you just have to add batteries.
But that will
essentially-- and you
can do transformations as well.
You can have different
voltage levels in your system,
but that adds to the complexity.
Thermal flux is essentially
heat flux, dq dt.
There are three fundamental
mechanisms of heat transfer--
conduction, convection,
and radiation.
In spacecraft, radiation is
probably the most important
because that's the
only way to get rid
of heat out of your spacecraft.
And then you can do conduction
and convection internally.
RF power, so microwaves.
Transmitting or
transferring power
through microwaves is becoming--
of course, we now had microwave
ovens for a long time.
But even doing power beaming
over larger distances
with microwaves is
definitely something
that's been
demonstrated, and there's
a lot of interest in it.
Here also, we are pretty
standard frequencies, so
2.4 gigahertz, 5.8 gigahertz.
You have a whole industry
built around these standards.
By the way, why
the 2.4 gigahertz?
Let's see if-- at MIT.
This 2.4 gigahertz
for microwaves,
where does that come from?
Anybody know where
that comes from?
AUDIENCE: Is that the frequency
that can be transmitted easily
through the atmosphere?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Actually,
no, it's not good.
It's absorbed.
It's absorbed in the atmosphere.
It's the opposite.
This 2.4 is very
important because it's
a resonant frequency
of the water molecule.
So your microwave oven
will work at 2.4 gigahertz.
Why?
Because if you radiate
microwaves at that frequency,
it makes the water molecules
vibrate because that's
a resonant frequency, and
you transfer a lot of heat
or a lot of energy into
your water molecules, which
are the majority of your food.
So it's actually
really bad for--
you'd like to use 2.4
gigahertz, but if you
try to use that frequency for
atmospheric power transfer,
you're right at
the resonant mode.
So if you have a high level
of humidity in the air,
you're going to lose
a lot of that power,
just heating the atmosphere up
and not transmitting the power.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
And then another very popular
frequency is 5.8 gigahertz.
And then we can go to
X band, which is closer
to 8 gigahertz, et cetera.
But anyway, so this is
a kind of growing area
is microwave power transfer.
And then of course, the
more old-fashioned, perhaps,
but still very important
is mechanical power,
so transferring energy and power
through a mechanical interface.
So if it's linear, it's
force times velocity.
If it's rotary, it's torque
times the angular rate
of rotation.
And then finally, energy--
typically, if you want
to have energy flow,
it does imply that there's a
physical connection as well,
like some kind of wires or a
gearbox or something like this.
However, a lot of interest now
in wireless power transfer.
But it's still kind of a--
for it to really work
reliably at high power levels,
this is pretty immature
technology still.
So here's some examples of--
again, this is from xerography.
And you'll understand
why I'm using
these examples in a minute.
So we have a paper.
We have toner, unfused toner.
And we want to fuse
those two together.
We do this through a heat
roller and heat and a belt.
And essentially,
we're transferring
energy from the heat
roll to the paper, which
allows it to fuse the toner.
So we have transfer of
energy from one to two,
which is shown by this
green mark here in the DSM.
So heat energy is transferred
from system one to system two.
One question that often
comes up is, well,
what if we have like waste heat?
There's heat losses, and
there's parasitic energy flows.
Do we care about those?
Do we represent those?
And the answer is
yes, you should,
especially if they
affect your performance
or your requirements.
So the first thing
you typically do,
as you map out your
interfaces, is you
map the flows that you want to
happen, that need to happen.
And then on top of
that, you map out
the flows that happen
even though you
didn't design for that, but
you need to account for them.
So heat losses would be an
example of that waste heat
flux.
Any questions about
energy or power flows?
MIT, any questions,
energy or power flux?
AUDIENCE: We're good, thanks.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
Next one, mass flows.
Mass flows is when
matter, physical matter,
is being exchanged between
two elements or subsystems.
So mass flows is dm dt,
kilograms per second.
And the form of the matter
can be fluids, gases, solids.
I guess plasma as well.
There's a big plasma
center here on campus.
But the primary three are
fluids-- so if it's fluids,
it could be like a cooling
liquid, a refrigerant, fuel,
water.
If it's gases, air, exhaust gas.
And then for solids, examples
would be toner, paper.
If you're in the mining
industry, it's iron ore.
And typically, mass flow
implies an underlying
physical connection, like some
kind of channel or conduit.
So Rafael, your example of your
sucking up and melting the snow
and you said there's a hose, so
the hose is itself a component,
but it enables the mass
flow of the melted snow
into some holding
tank or reservoir.
And so the hose is the
physical connection.
And then the mass flow
that happens through
that hose is what's shown here.
Mass flows can be open.
So there's a source
and there's a sink.
The source and the sink could
be inside or outside your system
boundary.
You have to think about it.
But also, mass flows can form
continuous loops, particularly
if you recycle things.
Like for example,
in the refrigerator,
your cooling liquid continuously
cycles through your system.
So here's some
examples of mass flows.
We have a heat exchanger.
This is a U-type heat exchanger.
So on the top, we have what's
called here the shell side.
A fluid is coming in and
is running out on this end.
And then we have
horizontally, a fluid
that's coming in
on the lower side,
cycling through, exchanging
the heat, and moving out.
So a heat exchanger
is interesting
because what kind
of flows happen
in a heat exchanger of the
flows we've discussed so far?
Energy and mass flow, right?
So the two of them
happen together.
In order for the energy flow to
happen or transfer to happen,
the mass flow has
to happen as well.
So these two flows are
tied to each other.
Here's an example
from xerography.
So we have our
photoreceptor belt.
We have residual toner
on the photoreceptor
that needs to be removed
from the photoreceptor.
And we do this through a
cleaning lamp, and then
a blade.
So in this case, you
can show this as an OPM,
and then you can show it here
where that residual toner is
transferred from photoreceptor
one to the cleaning blade two.
And this is shown in the DSM
as a mass flow from one to two.
And then we have one more,
which is the information flows.
So this is really where
the big revolution
has happened in the
last two decades
since a lot of
functions that used
to be done mechanically have
been replaced with software.
And here's some examples
of these information flows.
So if your system has a
user interface, a GUI,
a graphical user interface, or
some kind of I/O, input/output,
with the user, that's critical.
That's an information interface.
And so Rafael, again coming
to your presentation--
so I'm going to pick
on you a lot today.
Not pick on you, but I'm
going to cite you a lot.
You said this rover is going to
be controlled somehow, right?
And the big question is
always, how much autonomy
do you put inside the
thing, and how much do you
rely on a user that's remote?
And that's clearly an
information interface.
The nature of the
information, is it analog?
Is it digital?
Is it wireless?
So on the analog side,
we're essentially
talking about some
signal, some voltage,
and there's been a lot
of work done on ADC,
analog-to-digital conversion.
And then the opposite
is digital to analog.
And depending on how many bits
you have available to you,
you're going to have some
discretization errors.
A purely digital interface,
we refer to it as DIO,
Digital Input/Output.
And then of course,
wireless, this
is the standard,
the 802.11 standard,
which is really very
important these days.
If you think about
why we need all this,
mainly, the main reason
is control, right?
We have sensors,
actuators, controllers.
And because this information
is never perfect--
there's gaps in the information
or there's noise superimposed--
we have to also filter and
amplify the information.
And so if you think about the
type of information flows--
for example, in spacecraft, we
could have telemetry, sensor
data.
And telemetry
fundamentally means,
I want to know how
is my system doing.
Is it healthy?
Are all the subsystems working?
Are there some anomalies?
Are components within
their temperature limits?
That's what we call telemetry.
And then commands are when
you are sending a command
to the system and say, you know,
turn this way, turn that way.
And fundamentally,
telemetry and commands
are treated quite differently.
So where do you need
better quality information?
Where is the link
more important,
on the telemetry side
or sending commands?
What do you think?
Actually, no.
So if your telemetry
is imperfect--
I mean, it depends a little
bit what you do with it.
But the commands are
typically more critical.
Like, if you have a
bit error in a command,
and it says fire
the engine but you
didn't want to fire the engine,
you can lose your mission.
So typically, what's
known as the bit error
rate has to be lower,
meaning the link budget is
much better for commands.
So there's an asymmetry.
OK, so here's some examples.
So here's a typical
control loop.
You have your plants, your
system, your actuator, sensors,
a comparator that compares
your reference signal--
this is how you want
the system to behave--
and sends that to a controller,
which then closes the loop.
The example here,
again from xerography,
is you have some
original document.
You want to make a copy here.
So there's a lamp that shines
light onto your document.
It goes through a
lens, a laser diode,
and then to your marking system.
The OPM, you have your
original, your optical system.
You create a digital
image file which then
is sent to the marking system.
So if we simplify
all this, we can
say there's information
flow from the optical system
to the marking system.
From one to two,
information is transferred.
So any questions?
So those are the four
fundamental types
of interfaces and
examples with that.
And so the theory, what the
theory of design tells us
is that this is universal.
Any kind of interface falls
into one of these types.
And in fact, even in
biological systems that's true.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When we have
a system [INAUDIBLE]??
OLIVIER DE WECK: I'll show
that to you in the DSM.
You actually track
them separately,
but they're within the same--
it's one big interface, but it
has these different subflows
within it, which means that--
it's not just the fact
that there is an interface,
but the complexity of the
interface is important.
So the most complex
interfaces obviously
would be the ones where you
have all four types, right?
It's a physical connection, and
there's an information flow,
and there's an energy
flow, and there's
a mass flow across
the interface.
Usually, it's only
a subset of those,
but you can have interfaces
where you have all these four
present at once.
Any questions about these
types of interfaces at MIT?
AUDIENCE: No, we're good.
Thank you.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
In general, can you
hear better now?
Is it pretty stable over there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Good, all right.
So let me talk about DSM.
[INAUDIBLE] was
asking about DSM.
So DSM is a fairly recent
method, the last couple
of decades, for really
making a map of your system
that shows explicitly
these interfaces.
So here's a very simple example.
This is a sample system
with five components.
It has a pump, a controller,
a motor, a valve, a filter.
And in this case,
we have mass flow
from the pump through the
valve into the filter.
And so this block diagram
on the upper left,
the exact same information
is contained in this matrix.
So a DSM is always
a square matrix
where your components are
the rows and columns, equally
labeled.
And the diagonals here,
there's no information
on the diagonals.
So the component connects
with itself, obviously.
So you keep the
diagonals sort of blank.
And then all of those interfaces
and flows we mentioned
are shown as off-diagonals.
You have to be a little
careful because there's
two definitions of DSM depending
on the inflows and then
the outflows.
So the definition that we
mainly use in North America
is where the inflows into
a component are horizontal.
So the controller sends
information to the valve.
This is that blue
square right there.
And you can see that's shown
here on the block diagram.
But the valve also
sends information back
to the controller.
And that information
would probably be,
valve should open or close.
And when the valve
is actually opened,
it would confirm that
back to the controller
that the status of the
valve is open or closed.
And then we have
the energy flows.
The numbers that
are shown here, I
don't want to get
too much into this,
but there's a really
cool binary scheme
for putting a number
that you can then
have one number in that cell.
And based on that, you can,
through the binary code,
reverse engineer what
kind of interface is it.
Is it just physical?
Is it just binary?
It's a kind of trick for
replacing these colors
and cells with
just a number that
allows you to then reverse
engineer what kind of interface
is it.
So if it's empty, it means
there's no direct connection.
And then you have mechanical,
mass flows, information,
and energy flows.
So let me show you this on
a real example in a minute.
So this method, design
structure matrix method,
there's some synonyms for it--
design dependency
matrix, n-squared matrix,
n-squared diagram.
In matrix or graph theory, it's
called an adjacency matrix.
Don't be fooled;
it's the same thing.
It's just a square
matrix that shows
you what connects to what.
And then the simplest one is
just a binary, 0's and 1's.
But the richer DSMs, they
contain more information
about the type of interface.
So a lot of work
was done originally
by Don Steward on this.
This is an original
reference from '81.
And then at MIT, Professor Steve
Eppinger at the Sloan School
has done a lot of work on DSMs.
So fundamentally, it's
a matrix representation
of your product architecture.
Most of the literature
you find just
uses the simplest,
this binary DSM.
But I'm actually a fan
of adding information
into the DSM that tells
you about the physics
of the interface as well.
So let's look at
an example here.
Do you remember the
refrigerator case study
we did a few sessions ago?
So this is a liaison diagram,
level one decomposition.
So the refrigerator's been
decomposed into 10 components--
the door, the
condenser, power supply,
all the way to the compressor.
And all we're doing
here is saying
what is physically
connected to what.
And the reason it's
called a liaison diagram
is because it's going to help
you think about the assembly
sequence of how this
should be put together.
So another way to think about
this is like the skeleton.
This is the skeleton
of your system.
So if you do have a liaison
diagram, shown again--
this is the same one
on the left here--
you can just translate
that to a matrix.
The matrix, this DSM here,
I'm using X's instead of 1's.
But these two contain
exactly the same information.
One is a graph view, and
the other is a matrix view,
but they're identical--
the same thing, the
same information,
just presented in
a different way.
And of course, if you pay
close attention to the matrix,
you'll see it's
actually symmetric.
So then we can say, well,
what kinds of interfaces?
And here come the four
types that we just
discussed-- the physical
connection, energy flow,
mass flow, and information flow.
So if we apply that idea
to the refrigerator,
here's our 10 by 10
physical connections.
So we have a design
scripture matrix
with only the black marks.
So it's symmetric.
And this reflects
the liaison diagram.
And then we can add, on top
of that, the mass flows, which
are in red.
So the mass flows,
the way you read
this is we have a mass
flow from the compressor
to the condenser, and
then from the condenser
to the evaporator, and then
from the evaporator back
to the compressor.
Do you see that?
And we could rearrange these
to be closer to each other.
We could regroup the DSM.
But essentially, these red marks
represent the refrigerant cycle
within the refrigerator,
within the machine.
And so you can check by tracing
these from row to column.
You can actually check whether
the loop is properly closed.
So then energy flows, since the
refrigerant loop that I just
talked to you
about is important,
you can see that
those connections
we just talked about always also
carry a energy flow with them.
And then finally, information
flow is very little.
So in this case, there's only
one that I've represented,
which is the flow from the
thermostat to the power supply.
The thermostat defines the
temperature at which you
want to hold the refrigerator.
And if temperature goes
up, the power supply
kicks in and drives
the compressor.
And as soon as the temperature
falls below some threshold,
then it reverses, and
the compressor turns off.
So when your
refrigerator kicks in,
that's an information
flow from the thermostat
to the compressor
to the power supply.
If you own one of those fancy,
new Samsung refrigerators where
the door has a flat screen TV
in it and you can push buttons,
there's a lot more blue here.
There would be a lot
more blue in a really
high-end refrigerator
these days.
OK, any-- yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah,
so the question--
I'm just going to repeat
the question-- is,
can you also map the
external interfaces?
And the answer is, absolutely.
So what you have
to do, though, then
is to kind of draw a
bigger box around this
and add here the
external elements--
so the human user, the wall
outlet, the grocery store,
wherever you're including in
your external world that's
interfacing with it.
You would have to represent
at least those elements that
have a direct connection
with any of it
across the system boundary.
You would add them
here, and then show--
but you would have to then
put a big box around it
to make it clear what's inside
the system and what's outside.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: That's correct.
That's correct.
And we can argue-- of
course for the refrigerator,
the main interface
that you typically
have-- well, there are two.
Let's say we go for
what you're saying.
We're going to add some
external interfaces.
For a refrigerator, what are
the two or three most important?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Correct.
So where would that enter here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: The
power supply, right?
So we would add,
like, wall AC power.
If we added that, then in this
cell corresponding to that,
you would have an
inflow of power.
And then--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: So
this is the power supply
inside of the refrigerator,
inside the system boundary.
But if you had the wall outlet,
then that would be an external.
And then you would have
an interface across,
but into the power supply.
So that's one.
What's the other one?
Do you remember we talked
about the Carnot cycle?
Well, yes, what do you
have to do with the heat?
AUDIENCE: Burn?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah, so the
heat has to be removed, right,
radiated out.
And where does that happen?
Which element here is where
the heat gets removed,
which one of these 10?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Not really.
The refrigerant does the
internal heat transfer,
but the heat transfer to
the outside, to the air.
Refrigerators don't work
well in vacuum chambers.
Remember that.
It would be the evaporator.
It's at the
evaporator that you're
radiating the heat
to the surrounding
air, the environment.
So you'd have the surrounding
air as an external system,
and then and energy
transfer from the evaporator
to the outside.
But it's a good question.
So you have to always
define your system boundary.
So the question then is, when
do you generate these DSMs?
And fundamentally, there's two
ways, top-down or bottom-up.
So top-down, you start with
a model of your system.
And we talked about those
system modeling languages,
like SysML, or in
this case, OPM.
And then you hide some things.
You hide attributes and states.
You collapse all
your processes into
these tagged structural links,
and then you generate your DSM.
And then the other way to do it
is bottom-up where you already
have a design or a system.
You decompose it.
For example, you do
a product dissection.
You do your bill of
materials or your parts list.
Then you do your
liaison diagram.
You show the
physical connections.
And then on top of those
physical connections,
you map your mass, energy
and information flows.
And once you have that, then you
can start manipulating the DSM.
You can group
components differently.
You can show modules
and so forth.
So I want to show you a real
world-- this is not just
sort of an academic example,
but this is a real-world example
of a DSM that we built for a
research project with Xerox.
The machine that's represented
here is in the upper right.
This is the iGen3
digital printing press.
And represented here is its
architecture, its interfaces,
as an 84 by 84 DSM.
So the machine has been
decomposed into 84, really,
subsystems, because you have
a lot more than 84 parts.
But at this level of
abstraction of 84 by 84,
we have a total of 572 physical
connections, 45 mass flows,
167 energy flows, and
165 information flows.
And there's a little
more detail here
in terms of the types of flows.
So in red, we have mass
flows-- paper, toner, air,
ozone and dirt, because you've
got to keep dirt out of the--
the printing engine is
shown here in the middle.
Let me just show this.
So you're probably
scratching your head now.
Ozone, really?
Ozone?
Why do we keep track of ozone?
What do you think?
Why do we care about ozone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
at ground level.
OLIVIER DE WECK: It's a
pollutant at ground level.
And where does the
pollutant come from?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: So it's
generated inside the machine.
The reason is these machines
use very high voltages.
Xerographic processes
use pretty high voltages.
So if you apply a
very high voltage,
you actually generate
ozone through a--
it's an electrochemical
reaction that
happens inside the machine.
Nobody used to care about
this until people working
in these print shops
started to feel symptoms
and started to complain.
So in the US, it's called OSHA.
That's the Occupation Safety
and Health Administration.
They came in, and they
took some measurements.
And wow, the ozone level
is through the roof.
It's multiple times above
the allowable maximum limit.
And the reason is
because of this kind
of xerographic process.
So now, these machines
have to control the ozone.
And essentially, this box here,
the printing engine, is sealed.
It has its own air
conditioning system
to prevent the ozone
from leaking out.
It's a great example of how
occupational safety drove
new requirements
which then increased
the complexity of the machine.
So we keep track
of the ozone flows.
And then in green, we
have the usual suspects--
high voltage, low voltage, DC,
mechanical energy, and then
heat energy.
So there's some coding
that goes on here.
So in total, we have 1,033
non-empty cells here,
which is about
3.7%, so about 4%.
This DSM has a
density of about 4%.
And that doesn't
sound very high.
But believe me, this is
a very complex machine.
This DSM that you see
here is version 31.
So it took 31 versions
to create this DSM.
And so why did it
take that long?
Because this was published
as an official document
capturing the architecture
of this machine.
So what that means in practice
is of these 84 components
or subsystems, every one of
those components or subsystems
is owned by a different
person or a different team.
And we went through a process
where all of these 84 teams,
for their component, had
to sign off and say, yep,
you've accurately
captured my interfaces.
My physical, mass, information
and energy interfaces
have been correctly
captured in this matrix.
And oh, by the way, the empty
cells have also been certified.
So if there's an
empty cell here,
there's no question
whether, well, maybe it's
just somebody forgot to
put the interface there.
No.
The owner of that row
and column certified
that there is no
direct interface
between this component
and the other component.
That's why it took 31 versions.
But now that you have this
map, you can do a lot of things
with it.
You can do
architectural analysis.
You can benchmark
against other products.
You can do what we call
technology infusion
analysis, which was done.
You can say, well,
what if we add
this feature in the machine?
OK, well, where is that
feature going to go?
What are the interfaces
of that new feature?
Do we have to
change the software?
physically integrate it?
This is a fantastic,
very powerful tool
for showing the interfaces
and managing them.
Any questions about
this DSM approach?
The real way to do this is to
actually build one yourself.
And you can see it's a lot of
work, but once you have it,
it's very powerful.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: So
there's templates,
like Excel templates.
But there's also software.
There's a website
called DSMweb.org.
And I'm happy to send that
out for you as a resource.
There's even yearly conferences.
There are DSM conferences
where people get together
from academia, from
different companies--
like BMW, for example.
I'm a big fan of BMW.
I think they do a great job.
Their system engineering
is very, very strong.
They use this on
all their vehicles,
on all their subsystems.
And so this
DSMweb.org, you'll see
sort of the software that's
available and so forth.
There's also some commercial
software available.
So yeah, please, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Ah.
So let's think about this.
The 7 plus or minus 2, how
does the 7 plus or minus
2 relate to the 84?
This is an 84 by 84 DSM.
So how do the two
relate to each other?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Right.
But what's the relationship of
that rule with the 84 by 84?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah, so
this machine might have--
if you really want
every little detail,
this is probably a
level 4, level 5, right?
But what's shown here, this
is essentially the equivalent
of a level two representation.
So do you remember
7 plus or minus
2 squared is somewhere between
25 at the low end and 81.
So we're just
slightly above this.
So my argument here is this
is essentially a level two
DSM where you decompose
the system down two levels,
and then you show the
DSM the interfaces
at this level of abstraction.
You could go level
three, but now you're
going to have a 500
by 500 DSM, which
is almost impossible for a human
to really understand and get
any use out of it.
There's also been some
work in hierarchical DSMs.
So for example, if you
look at the feeder system--
you see in the upper left
here that says "feeder"?
Well, what is the feeder?
It's all this upfront stuff that
feeds your paper and your media
into the print engine.
So you could take--
this is just two rows here.
You could take those and break
those into much greater detail.
So you'd have-- kind of like you
guys did the requirements tree,
the requirements hierarchy.
You can have a
hierarchy of DSMs.
I'm not showing that here,
but that's the relationship.
This is essentially a level
two decomposition DSM.
Good question.
MIT, any questions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just have
one question about the liaison
diagram.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there, I guess,
any meaning or information
that comes from the distances
between-- like when you draw
it, the way that you draw it?
OLIVIER DE WECK: No,
there really isn't.
So the tricky thing is if
it's a very complex system,
like if we did the liaison
diagram for the 84 by 84--
let me just go back here--
it would be pretty messy.
And so you want to sort of
do the layout of the liaison
diagram so you minimize the
number of crossing lines,
for example.
There's actually some graph
visualization algorithms
that try to create as clean
as possible of a graph.
One of those is--
it's called a spring
energy algorithm.
It basically treats these links
as though they were springs.
And then depending on
how far things are,
there's spring energy.
And you want to minimize the
total energy of the system.
And by doing that, usually,
the graph looks pretty clean.
But there's no inherent
meaning in how you lay it out.
Does that makes sense, Sam?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have
a question too--
OLIVIER DE WECK: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: --about
the liaison diagrams.
I was doing something
similar, at least where
I had each block as a
functional aspect of the system.
It was for an avionics system.
And I found that I needed
to, like, make power
a separate thing because
it was more of like a tree.
We had one power
distribution system.
But the thing I wanted to bring
up was the information flow.
Originally I just had
one color for that,
but I didn't find
that too useful.
What I plan on doing
is splitting it
up into command and telemetry.
So is drawing information just
as one entity typically done?
Because I think it's more useful
to have command and telemetry,
or like data and commands.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So
you know, that's fine.
And depending on what
you're going to use it for,
you can redefine the colors.
There's no global standard
for how to properly do a DSM.
That's still kind of evolving.
So if you have different types--
and you saw in
the Xerox example,
we used letters as well for the
different types of mass flows--
P for paper, T for toner.
So the way you're going to
code it is really up to you.
There's no global, right
one way to do it yet.
So that sounds good.
Actually, you did the
right thing there.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
OLIVIER DE WECK: How
are we doing time-wise?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What kind
of [INAUDIBLE]??
OLIVIER DE WECK: So
why are we doing this?
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Well, pretty pictures.
No, I'm sort of half-joking.
Part of it is definitely a
graphical, visual, powerful way
to convey the whole
system architecture.
If you think about it,
there aren't too many ways
of actually visualizing
the whole system.
This is a very abstract view.
But there's a-- and then
this DSM here at Xerox,
it printed out as a
huge, wall-sized poster.
And you put it on the wall.
And people actually go
up there and say, ah,
that's my subsystem.
And then they
argue and so forth.
So part of it is
definitely a visualization.
But the other thing
you can do with it,
particularly if you start
putting the numbers in,
you can use this for
complexity quantification.
So you can quantify the
complexity of your system
and then compare it
against a competing system
or a prior generation system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Correct.
AUDIENCE: You could not
have a macro view on it.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Right.
So this is a macro view,
but if you really-- then you
need to put numbers
for the component
complexities, the interface
complexities and so forth.
And there's quite a bit
of research in this.
So you can then move this
from a purely visual tool
to becoming an analytic tool.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah.
And one thing we'll
talk about next
is interface control documents
as an important-- so in theory,
in theory, every one
of these interfaces,
you can have a document
or a digital file
if you click on this.
And this is where the tools
are not fully mature yet.
But you'd like to be
able to click on this,
and then it links you
to another document.
And what is that other document?
It's the ICD, the
Interface Control Document
that defines that interface.
And then you have
a lot of details.
Like if it's an electrical
connector, how many pins,
what's the function of each pin?
And that's really where
things become useful, OK?
All right, let me move on.
But I did upload for you guys.
So it's really up to you if you
want to do a DSM at your PDR.
It would be nice, but
I don't absolutely--
if you like this, if
you think it's useful,
try it out for the PDR.
But it's not a
must-have requirement.
But in the full-year
SDM class that we teach,
we're just doing that right now.
And so you can
use it for reverse
engineering the architecture
of a software package.
You like open source software.
You just download it.
You generate a DSM,
and you can start
seeing what are the different
modules in the code, what
do they do, how do they
talk to each other.
It's incredibly powerful.
But what I did do is I
uploaded for you guys--
I said there's a
top-down, and then there's
a reverse engineering or
bottom-up way of doing it.
This is a 17-step
procedure, pretty detailed,
a document that I uploaded
under the reading section.
So if you go on the website,
under the reading section,
you will find--
this is like a four or five-page
document that says step
by step how do you do a DSM.
And again, so at a high level,
then, what you get out of it
is--
here, I've sort of
hidden the details
from what you saw before--
is the high-level
architecture you can see.
So in the case of
the Xerox example,
we have our frontend
system, the feeder system,
the main marking engine.
You can see the modules.
And then you have the
finishing system down here.
And so many systems and products
have similar architectures.
OK, any questions
before I move on.
Let's talk about ICDs,
Interface Control Documents.
And in the system engineering
engine from the handbook,
this is right here
in the middle.
This is the technical
management processes.
Number 12, interface management.
It's a huge deal.
If you don't do it
well, if you don't
do interface management well--
and we heard some examples--
it's really trouble.
So the purpose is for
controlling your development
effort.
It's really important-- I just
highlighted a few words here--
if you have geographically
diverse technical teams.
And maintaining
interface definition,
once you've decomposed your
system, is absolutely critical.
So let me talk briefly
about the different--
so this is a little bit
more like traditional system
engineering where you define
the interface with a document.
We've said that system
engineering is moving
to become more model-based.
We don't want big
piles of paper anymore.
But the reality is that many
projects and programs still
have a lot of these documents.
Ideally, you'd just have
a model, a digital model
of the interface.
Then you don't need
a separate document.
But if you are working with
suppliers or contractors that
don't have the same modeling
capability as you have,
these documents are critical.
So the first one, it's called
IRD, Interface Requirements
Document.
And this is-- do you remember
when you did the requirements
analysis in assignment two?
This is one of the six
classes of requirements
is interface requirements.
So that's the idea, is all
the interface requirements
are pulled together into an IRD.
It defines the
functional, performance,
electrical, environmental,
human, physical requirements
and constraints that exist at
the common boundary between two
or more functions
or system elements.
So you haven't designed the
interface yet, physically,
but you've defined what the
interface should be able to do,
its functionality.
Then we have-- this
is the most common.
You've probably heard
this acronym before--
is ICDs, Interface Control
Document or Interface Control
Drawing.
And so that is essentially the
specification of the interface.
What does the
interface look like?
So if you look at a ICD of
an electrical connector,
you'll see the pin-out,
you see the voltage levels,
you'll see the purpose of
each signal for each pin.
Maybe there's some pins
that are unused that
are reserved for future use.
That's also very
clearly defined.
And the key about the ICD is
it's a two-sided document.
So there's a subsystem
A and a subsystem B,
and they share a
common interface.
And the ICD, the Interface
Control Document,
will define both sides of
the interface as opposed
to IDD, Interface
Definition Document,
which is only a one-sided
or unilateral document.
So for example, let's
say your company makes
a very fancy camera or sensor
to be used on a spacecraft,
but you don't know who is
going to use that camera,
how are they going to use it.
So what you're
defining is essentially
your side of the interface--
physical, functional.
And then it's up to whoever
your customer is to take the IDD
and turn it into an ICD.
But the IDD is only
one-sided, unilateral.
And the ICD is bilateral,
interface definition.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So here's-- again, this
is from the handbook,
the system
engineering handbook--
interface management.
On the input side,
you start with
your interface
requirements, any changes
to the interface that come
up during the lifecycle
of the project.
You go through the steps and
out come your interface control
documents, any requirements
changes, and then interface
management work
products, which might
be other supporting documents.
For example, a user manual
or an operator manual
that will actually tell you how
to properly use the interface
would be an example of
a supporting document.
OK, any questions
about that before we
get to system integration?
So who's actually
read an ICD or had
an actual ICD in their hands?
You have, yeah?
[INAUDIBLE],, I'm sure
you've had that many times.
Can you tell us what it was?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Let
me give you the mic.
So-- [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So we were
working on a project
where a Chinese asked us to
contribute a camera payload
for their satellites.
And so we had to define all the
electrical and data interfaces.
I was in charge of
the data interfaces.
And there were design documents
saying how will the interaction
work between the two systems.
Let's see.
Because [INAUDIBLE]
protocol, I had
to tell the satellites what to
do if the camera fails and how
should the camera
fail if there is
a problem on the computer,
so all the failure cases
and this kind of thing.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So it
sounds like [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's an ICD.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Good.
And was it used then, or--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Great, excellent.
Any examples of an ICD or
IDD or IRD on the MIT side?
Anybody have
experience with this?
AUDIENCE: No.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Was
that you, your honor?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I personally
have experience with ICDs,
but no one in the room does.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, well, why
don't you tell us about yours?
Because I know you worked on
this gravity gradient sensor.
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So
maybe that example.
Yeah, why don't you
tell us about that?
AUDIENCE: So each
system had its own ICD.
And that was primarily
because the rest of the team
needed to understand
the inputs and outputs
and how the specific
system works.
So it not only works
for system integration.
It just works for
the team as a whole
in its understanding
of the project
and the particular systems.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
All right, so this is a really,
really big deal in practice.
If you do something that's--
so for example, if
you make a design,
you modify the interface
because you think, ah,
it's better for me.
I'm going to change this.
And it's different from the ICD.
And then there's a
failure in your system.
And then you say you're going
to blame the supplier and say,
your box failed.
My mission got screwed
up because of your box.
And then it turns
out, ah, you actually
implemented an interface that's
in conflict with the ICD.
The supplier will step back
and say, that's not my problem.
You didn't follow the
interface definition,
and just changing one
pin or one polarity
can lead to a system failure.
So really, you have to
pay a lot of attention
to the details here.
OK, let's talk about
system integration.
So what is it?
It's essentially the
process of deliberately--
so let's say you've
designed your system.
The interfaces are clear.
When you physically put
together your system,
you have to
integrate the system.
So that means different things.
Physical assembly
of the parts, that's
the liaison diagram,
what fits into what.
And we'll talk about
sequencing in a minute.
You need to connect your
different conduits and hoses.
You need to fill in
various consumables--
fuel, lubricants.
An example in space
flight would be
if you're going to
use a cryocooler,
you might have to use
some gases or liquids
for the cyrocooler
that are consumables,
finite consumables.
Connecting all your electronics
to the power sources,
the avionics.
Wire harnesses are
still used a lot.
We would love to get rid
of wire harnesses, right?
They're heavy.
They're cumbersome.
They're expensive.
And we've been trying to replace
wire harnesses with wireless,
but it's really hard to
make it work reliably.
So we still use wire
harnesses quite a bit.
And then you need
to upload and test
your operational software
that sits inside your system.
So that's a lot of work, and it
has to be done very carefully.
A lot of this is
done in facilities
that are very
clean, clean rooms,
because you really need
to do every step properly.
You need to document every step.
There's quality control.
And that's why it's
expensive and slow.
So the next point
here is the sequence
in which the integration
occurs may be important.
And I want to--
so the reading, the post-reading
associated with this lecture,
is a paper by Ben-Asher, who's a
professor at Technion in Israel
who I think has done some of
the best work, theoretical work,
on system integration.
And unfortunately, in complex
systems, a lot of problems
are errors.
We often discover them during
system integration and testing.
So that's also a key point here.
OK, so let me--
I hope you have a chance to
read this Ben-Asher paper,
because it's pretty interesting.
But I'll give you sort of the
summary here on one slide.
So what they looked
at was, does it
matter whether you do a
single-stage integration,
everything at once,
or you do what's
called incremental integration?
So the idea of
incremental integration
is you just integrate two
components or subsystems
in isolation at a time.
You check them, and then you
gradually integrate as opposed
to doing it all at once.
And the example in the paper is
UAV, Unmanned Aerial Vehicle.
And there's not a lot
of detail, but there's
four major subsystems--
the engine,
the flight control system,
the optronic payload,
and then the payload
control system.
And so in one case, you would
do a single-stage integration.
So here's your four
subsystems, and you just
integrate them all at once.
And that's shown here
in this upper graph.
So this is not the
graph of components.
This is the graph of
integration steps.
And then you have
to put the system,
once it's integrated, these
step seven, eight, nine,
through different tests.
And then the idea
is that the amount
of time that it takes to do
each of these integration steps
is somewhat stochastic.
It's not a deterministic number.
And so this upper
graph here that
looks kind of like a ski jump,
this is time, number of days,
versus the probability.
So what you see here is
that it's right-skewed--
or left-skewed, depending
on how you define it.
But the peak here
is to the right.
And so the idea is that if
everything goes super smoothly,
actually, single-stage
integration
could work very well.
But the likelihood of that
happening is not high.
And if you think about
it, if you do all at once,
single-stage integration,
troubleshooting
becomes more complex as well.
And so that's why this curve is
actually shifted to the right.
Incremental integration,
in this case,
you're just integrating two
and two, two and two, and then
you integrate your
pre-integrated subsystems
together.
So it looks more gradual.
And then here is--
again, using their model.
They have made certain
assumptions about this--
you get a somewhat broader
distribution of outcomes.
But the mean, the expected
amount of time for integration,
is actually less.
So you have a faster
integration time
on average with
incremental approach.
But in the worst case, you
may be a little bit longer
than the single-stage
integration.
But what really matters
is, what's the average?
So the conclusion in the
paper is that the integration
sequence is important, that
the integration sequence can
be optimized, that
there's advantages
of doing incremental
integration,
primarily from a
risk perspective.
So again, Octanus 1
project, maybe you guys
haven't thought about
this too much yet.
Maybe you have.
But when you do
your final vehicle,
the sequence in which everything
gets integrated and tested
is important.
That's really what this says.
And an incremental approach
can be very helpful.
The more components
you have, the more
the combinatorial
space of integration
sequences gets
bigger and bigger.
So you have to do this at
some level of abstraction.
Is that clear?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah.
And so the way you
describe-- this
is driven by your supply chain.
When are things
becoming available?
But you have to be
careful because it could
be sort of risk-driven as well.
So OK, good.
Any questions at MIT?
Any comments about this?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yup.
AUDIENCE: So I
guess the takeaway
is that incremental integration
is usually preferred
for most things, on average?
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yeah, I'm not sure.
Read the paper.
I think the conclusion
is that for new systems
that you've never
integrated before,
where your level of knowledge
and the TRL levels-- or you've
never done this before, first
of a kind of integration,
that incremental is better
because if there's a problem,
then troubleshooting is easier.
Now, if you're integrating
a very well known system--
so it's sort of the 10th system,
but you've sort of figured out
where the bugs are--
so the risk level, the
uncertainty is low.
Maybe then, single-stage
integration is OK.
So it really depends on
the novelty and risk.
So I don't think the
conclusion of the paper
is single-stage
integration is bad, always.
I think it's that you
should think carefully
about the sequencing, and it's
driven by the amount of risk.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
All right, good.
So we're almost at the end here.
I want to ask you
a quick question.
This is our concept
question for today.
And this is about
interface standards.
So over time in
different industries,
rather than
reinventing the wheel
and coming up with custom
interfaces for every project
you do, you say,
do the interface
according to this
standard or that standard.
So I'm just curious to
know from you guys--
and I asked this question
last week from another class
I teach at MIT.
So please answer this, and then
I'm going to show your answers
and the answers of the
other class combined.
So the interface
definitions here are 802.11,
[? MIL-STD-1553, ?]
RS-232, BB_aJ23100.
And then if you know of any
other interface standards
that you think are
important, just click Other.
This is a multi--
there's not just one
right answer here.
This is a
multi-checkbox question.
All right, so here's
the responses.
So 56%-- so this
is your results,
and then my class from last
week, kind of mixed together.
So 56% know the 802.11.
So what is--
I thought it might be more
than 56%, but what is 802.11?
AUDIENCE: Wi-Fi.
OLIVIER DE WECK: It's the
Wi-Fi standard, right?
And now, G I think is
the latest, I think.
It's sort of ABC, 802.11 ABC.
So it's kind of
evolving standard--
very important, obviously.
[? MIL-STD-1553, ?] 24%
know about that one.
Anybody here, any [INAUDIBLE],,
[? MIL-STD-1553? ?] So
you've done rural
engineering, I can tell.
So what is the 1553?
AUDIENCE: It's [INAUDIBLE].
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yes, it's a DoD.
So that's what's a
military standard.
It's essentially a data bus.
So for example, on military
planes, on many satellites,
it's essentially the
architecture of the avionics.
It's a bus architecture.
So you typically have like
a mission computer that's
the brain, and then it
directs how the messages
are sent from the different--
like the flight control
system or the payload.
It's kind of an old standard,
but it's a very robust standard
for avionics architectures.
OK, at MIT, RS-232?
This is also kind of
an older standard.
Anybody chose that?
AUDIENCE: It's a--
OLIVIER DE WECK: Did anybody--
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: --communication
protocol for electronics.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Right, but
it's a very specific one.
There's a keyword
I'm looking for.
AUDIENCE: Serial.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Serial, right.
It's a serial
interface, as opposed
to a parallel interface.
So it's a serial interface.
And still, it's kind
of old-fashioned,
but it's still used.
All right, now comes BB_aJ23100.
And nobody, out of
119, knew what that is.
So-- and this is kind
of a trick question--
this is a BioBricks interface.
So are you familiar
with synthetic biology?
So synthetic biology,
the basic idea
is that you can do what we do
here for biological systems.
So there's libraries of
parts, standard library
of biological parts,
like different proteins,
that you can actually
assemble organisms.
There's an annual competition.
It's been going on for
almost a decade now.
It's kind of scary, actually.
But so far, nothing really
bad has happened, I guess.
But the idea is that in
biology, it's going this way.
So you can look this up.
You can google for this
particular reference,
and it'll guide you to
essentially a protein
interface.
It's essentially a molecular,
biological interface.
So the prediction here is that
10, 20, 30 years from now,
people will know what this is.
And there will be a very
internationally recognized set
of biological interfaces that
people actually use and know.
And then anybody
chose Other here?
Anybody choose other?
Yeah, you did?
AUDIENCE: Like
standard USB and HDMI?
OLIVIER DE WECK: And USB
has evolved as well, right?
We had USB 1.0,
and then USB 2.0.
Isn't that the latest still?
AUDIENCE: USB-C.
OLIVIER DE WECK: C, OK.
AUDIENCE: It's reversible.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yeah, so standards
evolve as well, right,
as the technology
behind the standards-- you know.
So this is a huge
deal in practice.
Anybody at MIT chose
Other, other examples?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I chose Other.
Things that come to mind
are like SPI and I2C,
more like serial electronic
communication protocols
that are useful for
talking to chips.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
So those are sort of
inside the IC world, right?
OK, excellent.
So all right, well,
we are actually
at the end of today's lecture.
So I just want to
summarize the key points.
Why is interface
management important?
There are many reasons, but I
think the two top reasons are--
think of interfaces as a
potential Achilles heel.
They're potentially
seeds for failures.
We saw bottlenecks.
We saw structural failures.
We saw the wrong
kind of information
being passed through software.
And so be careful.
And if there's nobody in
charge in your project
to really look after the
interfaces, that's a problem.
So you want to really
think about this
because almost any project
today, you're decomposing it,
and you're not doing
everything in-house yourself.
You're going to
deal with suppliers.
deal with partners.
So of course you have an
organizational, contractual
interface with them, but there's
a physical interface as well.
The longer you wait to
define that interface
with your partners and
suppliers, the fuzzier it is,
the more problems you will have.
So critical to really
define the interface,
and then stick with the
interface very sharply.
Interface management has
different aspects to it.
So first of all,
types of interfaces,
there are many, many
dozens or hundreds
of types of interfaces, but
they can all be boiled down
to the four canonical types--
physical connection, mass,
energy, and information flows.
I've introduced you to the DSM,
the Design Structure Matrix
method.
And that's where you basically
decompose your system,
and you show it as
an n by n matrix.
And then you put
all the interfaces
into that matrix
that you know about,
not just the interfaces
that you want to have,
but the interfaces that
are actually there.
So if there's noise,
or vibration, or EMI,
Electromagnetic
Interference, or waste heat,
those are also
important because you're
going to have to deal
with them in some way.
Finally, ICDs.
So ICDS-- and we said there's
IRDs, Interface Requirements
Documents, which are the
requirements for the interface;
IDDs, one-sided; and then
ICDs are the most important.
It's the two-sided
interface definition.
That's the NASA approach,
but [? ISA ?] uses that.
Many, many industries now
use these interface control
documents.
Ideally, in the long-term,
we want to get rid of them.
We don't want documents
in system engineering.
We just want to have
models that we share.
But it's still moving
in that direction.
OK, and then finally,
the point about system
integration-- do not
just do it randomly.
Think about, how will you
assemble the system physically?
How are you going to connect
all your electronics,
the consumables?
How will you load your software?
How will you test it?
We'll talk about testing,
verification and validation
next week, but the way
in which you integrate,
the sequence of integration
could be very important.
And it's a pretty
active area of research,
so in sort of system
engineering research,
is really understanding and
modeling system integration
as something you can optimize.
And then the last point
was industry standards.
Really understand what
are the key standards
in your industry, what are
the key interface standards.
And if you're going
to deviate, if you're
going to choose something else
than an industry standard,
you better know why
you're doing it.
Because the minute you
decide not to use an industry
standard, you've probably
just inflated the cost
by a factor of 10 because
now there's no longer
any off-the-shelf components.
You have to basically
do everything yourself,
but it's possible that there's
good reasons for doing that.